В  Україні почастішали замахи з використанням вибухівки,
які часто стаються просто посеред міст.
Жертвами деяких з них ставали не лише об’єкти замаху, а й сторонні люди.
Більшість цих справ ще не розкриті і не доведені до суду.
DW зібрало перелік гучних замахів.
Ігор Мосійчук
Імовірний замах на депутата від фракції
"Радикальна партія Олега Ляшка" Ігоря Мосійчука
стався ввечері 25 жовтня, коли він виходив
з телеканалу «Еспресо» в Києві.
Здетонувала вибухівка, яку зловмисники заклали у мотоцикл,
що стояв поруч з автівкою депутата.
Через  вибух загинули охоронець Мосійчука та поліцейський,
що проходив повз.  Ще кілька людей
отримали поранення різного ступеня тяжкості.
Алі Тімаєв
У вересні в центрі Києва підірвали автомобіль
члена добровольчого батальйону Алі Тімаєва,
відомого на прізвисько Тимур Махаурі.
Він помер на місці, а дружина і дитина,
які також були в автомобілі,
отримали поранення та опіки.
Тімаєв був чеченцем за походженням, громадянином Грузії,
воював і в російсько-грузинській війні, і на Сході України.
В СБУ заявляли, що за замахом
стоять або російські, або чеченські спецслужби,
утім ця версія не доведена.
Максим Шаповал
У червні цього року в Києві підірвали
автомобіль командира спецназу Головного управління розвідки
Міноборони Максима Шаповала.
Вибухівку заклали під машину.
Від потужного вибуху військовий загинув на місці,
а двоє перехожих отримали осколкові поранення.
Загиблий очолював першу групу спецназу,
яка звільняла Донецький аеропорт у 2014 році.
Олександр Хараберюш
У березні цього року у житловому кварталі Маріуполя
підірвали автомобіль заступника начальника управління контррозвідки
донецької  СБУ Олександра Хараберюша.
Вибух був настільки потужний,
що вибив вікна у сусідніх будинках.
Контррозвідник одразу помер.
Вбивство пов’язують з його професійною діяльністю.
Павло Шеремет
Одне з найгучніших убивств сталося у липні минулого року,
коли  у центрі Києва підірвали автомобіль,
якому перебував відомий журналіст Павло Шеремет.
Вибухівка була закладена під машину з боку водія.
За понад рік розслідування слідчі не просунулись у справі,
окрім того, що  назвали чотири версії вбивства –
професійна діяльність, особисті мотиви, "російський слід"
чи замах на  журналістку Олену Притулу,
якій належав автомобіль.